ted is directed by seth macfarlane and
stars Mark Wahlberg Mila Kunis Joel
McHale and Seth MacFarlane as the voice
of little teddy bear now when Mark
Wahlberg was a little boy he wished for
a best friend his parents got him as
teddy bear and it came alive and became
his best friend it was a sweet little
relationship you know Ted's just a nice
little bear he's got this little
high-pitched voice I think whenever you
squeeze him he says I love you now we
got till later Mark Wahlberg's 35 years
old he still owes but Edna's house and
he's going out with Mila Kunis and the
whole thing is that Mark Wahlberg still
has this man boy thing and he's there
with Ted his best friend's a teddy bear
now this movie's directed by Seth
MacFarlane okay the creator of Family
Guy so you know this movie's more than
likely gonna be racist offensive
stereotypical des genders just have a
whole bunch of raunchiness in it well at
the same time being frickin hilarious I
had a lot fun with Ted Ted I laughed a
lot during this movie I really honestly
consistent laugh from beginning to end
all the way through I was gut busting my
butt off during this movie there were
scenes in this movie that were so funny
that I couldn't actually get over them
when they actually ended and some of the
audience members were like still
cracking up and you could hear people
like going like Wahlberg is so good here
I mean I thought he was really funny in
the other guys but here he just he was
really good in this movie he honestly
was my favorite part of this movie the
way he interacted with this the teddy
bear the CGI teddy bear and everything
I'm sure Seth MacFarlane must have been
reading the dialogue off camera
somewhere but they just had great
interaction with each other
Mila Kunis is really good as well I
thought Seth MacFarlane was good as the
bear even though he sounds a lot like
Peter Griffin but they even joke about
that in the movie at one part I was
actually surprised by that now yes there
are a lot of comparisons to Family Guy
in this movie and really honestly it is
kind of like a film version of a very
long episode of Family Guy I mean it's
got like a huge elaborate fight scene
all those jokes with her like haunts
sucks this reminds me of that one time
back in the day when this happened and
then little cut to that and you know
it'll be funny and they'll cut back you
know that Family Guy think if you like
Family Guy you'll really like this movie
if you're annoyed by a Family Guy
stay away cuz this is definitely very
Seth MacFarlane I mean he's all over
this movie but so the movie had a good
heart to it also it wasn't just watch
there's a lot of offensive jokes in it
yes I'm not bothered by that kind of
stuff there were jokes that were even
directed directly at a person like me I
didn't care what have her there's a lot
of film references in this movie too
like if you understand like music and
film
the 80s and 90s you're gonna get a lot
of jokes in this movie and you're gonna
be really surprised the many references
they're gonna pull up because there were
a lot of things there's like wow someone
else besides me actually knows about
that I'm gonna say Flash Gordon from the
80s all right if you're a fan of that
movie or think it's a so bad that it's a
good type of movie you are gonna be
rolling during this movie I mean the kid
has an Indiana Jones and the Temple of
Doom poster when he's growing up I have
one too I thought that was awesome but
honestly this was just a really
entertaining movie and Wahlberg really
carried it he was just a really good
presence in this movie I mean I just I
bought his character he wasn't over the
top he played off of ten really well
he had that straight man by but he was
also able to pulling a lot of jokes as
well Joel Mikhail's in this movie and I
think he's a funny guy but he's really
playing a lot of jerks lately you know I
would like him to play someone that's
not a jerk I don't know he did a good
job though in the movie he did well for
his scenes for sure I'd he actually had
one of the biggest laughs in the whole
movie for me it was just one scene he
had that I honestly could not stop
laughing and I had to like contain
myself because the scene had long past
he did a good job my only issue with
this movie is the fact that it kind of
falls into that comedy cliche where they
feel like at the end everything has to
get all serious that it has to be like a
big action scene or something some
elaborate thing to close out the movie
and basically the whole finale of the
movie was just kind of weak to me and a
little overly serious but you deal with
it and when I rate comedies to me it's
how much do you laugh you know how much
do you actually live from this movie and
I laugh almost from beginning to end I
really enjoyed Ted I'm gonna give it a
B+ so let you know the collaboration I'm
doing right now with the schmoes know we
just reviewed Batman Forever that's on
the schmoes Channel we're gonna go check
that out now let us know what you think
in the video and as always guys if you
liked this review you can subscribe to
my channel and get stuck my nice
[Music]